even in the most protected parts of the
brazilian amazon there's money to be
made
these are areas the federal government
says must not be destroyed they've made
it a crime
but sky news can show that this year
deforestation in these protected areas
is at record levels brazil is losing a
lot and brazilian people are losing
brazil's president has promised to
tackle illegal deforestation but under
his government it's increased
significantly
and powerful local politicians and
business owners are at the heart of it
[Music]
tucked away deep inside the rainforest a
man brings his light aircraft into land
these hidden airstrips allow deforesters
access to remote areas they can exploit
for cash
deforestation illegal or otherwise by
cattle ranchers gold miners and loggers
is happening right across the amazon
thousands of people rely on it for their
livelihood in places like novo progresso
this town was nothing more than a secret
airstrip tucked away inside the forest
just a generation ago
these days it's a bustling hub home to a
population of over 25 000 people
but this growth comes at a cost
the federal government and politicians
that are supporting this government give
impression for those that
are
doing these crimes that is okay to do
the town sits right on the edge of a
designated protected area of the forest
and we found that deforestation in
places like this is at record levels
this year
the dark plots on the map mean that
deforestation may have occurred in that
area
they're not actual deforestation which
is only verified and published at the
end of the year
but alerts give us a reliable indication
of current deforestation levels
between january and august this year
more than 2 300 square miles across the
brazilian amazon have been affected by
warnings according to sky news's
analysis of satellite data this level is
similar to those in 2019 and 2020 which
recorded the highest levels of
deforestation since 2008. over 9 000
square miles of forest have been
affected since president bolsonaro took
office in 2019. most of the warnings
were recorded outside of protected
regions even inside these areas where
it's almost always illegal to clear the
land we found deforestation is
accelerating
in the state of purat when novo
progresso is situated it's particularly
bad
the town borders jamaican national
forest a protected area
since bolsonaro's presidency the average
amount of forest affected by alerts each
year is nearly five times what it was in
the two years before
using satellite imagery we discovered
this area
in june 2020 it appears untouched
by july 2021 it's patchy and brown
the area is being deforested and we
found out who's behind it
the neighbouring plot of lang gave us a
clue
it's an area registered to a key
political figure in novo progresso he's
one of four consecutive former mayors of
the town to have been fined for damaging
protected parts of the forest
his one-time deputy who's now the mayor
of novo progresso was fined as recently
as august 2020
but how does that relate to our other
plot well using this clue public
databases and some details given to us
by the brazilian environment agency we
were able to track down the person
authorities believe deforested this area
our investigation once again led us back
to a group of local elites
this time the fine was handed to a
martyr smolsky dill
mother of the current mayor of novo
progresso gelsendell
miss dilla's twice run for novo
progresso council and runs a hotel in
the town
she did not respond when we approached
her for comments but it's not just local
political leaders there's a whole web of
individuals deforesting the area for
profit
23 local people were arrested back in
2014 in a major investigation
it included a man authorities have
called the biggest deforester in the
amazon ezekiel castano
he runs a local supermarket chain and
was accused of being in charge of a
strong scheme of land grabbing
deforestation and illegal sale of public
lands together and with the support of
other members of the gang authorities
allege the group use so-called laranja's
to hide their activities so they find a
brother-in-law or a or a friend
and that person is the official
owner of the land or official you know
owner of the company
and the person behind the facade is
pulling the strings and getting the
benefits and making all the decisions um
so that again is common in this in this
cases of
of deforestation and it makes it
difficult then to investigate who's
really responsible
it took six years to resolve the case
many of those charged ultimately
received suspended sentences
castano was found guilty of
deforestation but not of running an
organized gang
despite that conviction he has continued
to do business with local leaders this
document shows a contract he won in 2018
to provide local government with
supplies
the name of the company he runs sits
alongside that of the town's mayor at
the time
business leaders and politicians aren't
just breaking the law they're also
lobbying to change it
they want to reduce the size of the
jamaican forest to gain access to the
land
they feel the status of the park is an
unfair restriction for those who moved
to the area during the 70s and 80s on
the promise of economic prosperity
the current mayor has even met with
brazil's vice president to discuss the
cause
despite promising to protect the
rainforest president jair bolsonaro has
cut federal funding to many crucial
environmental agencies who are tasked
with maintaining managing and policing
the federal conservation units you have
a federal government where the president
is saying that he doesn't like
environmental ngos they're they're echo
terrorists
he doesn't trust his own data from np
because that's being done by you know
ngos that are that are echo terrorists
and so on so he's signaling to local
politicians
that the federal government is no longer
necessarily
a guardian of the forest
president bolsonaro said last week that
increased efforts to tackle illegal
activity have meant that deforestation
rates fell over 30 in august compared to
the same month last year
but as our investigation shows
deforestation levels have remained
consistently high since he came into
office
and its politicians and leaders at all
levels who are allowing it